MARK: HELLO AMERICA, I AM
MARK LEVIN, THIS IS "LIFE,
LIBERTY AND LEVIN."
SO WHAT DO WE MAKE OF LAST
TUESDAY?
SOMETIME A LITTLE TIME TO
DIGEST THESE THINGS IS
BETTER THAN ON THE SPOT
ANALYSIS, I NOTICED THAT
MANY OF STATEMENT PEOPLE WHO
WERE WRONG ABOUT A RED WAVE
NOW TELLING US WHAT TO THINK
ABOUT A NONRED WAVE.
WE NEED TO THINK FOR
OURSELVES.
I SAID BEFORE THE ELECTION,
AND I SAY HERE AND ON RADIO,
FORGET ABOUT THE RED WAVE,
FORGET ABOUT A RED TSUNAMI.
AND VOTE.
I SAID IT ON RADIO.
OVER AND OVER.
WHY?
WHO CARES WHO PEOPLE
PREDICT.
YOU HAVE TO GO OUT THERE AND
BRING HOME THE BACON.
THAT IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS WITH YOU AND WALK
THROUGH IT.
IT WILL BE DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT YOU ARE USED TO
HEARING, I HAVE GIVEN THIS A
LOT OF THOUGHT, SENATE
IN 2022, WE HAD 34 SEATS UP.
20 OF THEM WERE REPUBLICAN.
14 OF THEM DEMOCRAT.
THAT MEANT THAT REPUBLICANS
HAD TO DEFEND 20 SEATS.
IF THEY WERE GETTING MAKETY
MAJORITY THEY HAD TO
TAP TO 14.
THAT WAS A TALL HILL TO
CLIMB.
THE NEXT ELECTION CYCLE 33
SEATS ARE UP, 2/3 OF
DEMOCRAT SEATS, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO DEFEND 23
SENATE SEATS, AND
REPUBLICANS 10.
SO THE MATH IN 2022 NEVER
REALLY LEAD TO A RED WAVE
POSSIBILITY.
THE MATH IN 2024
DOES, DOES THAT MEAN THERE
WILL BE ONE IN, OF COURSE,
NOT, I AM JUST EXPLAINING
SIMPLE MATH.
WE HAVE ABOUT 60% OF SEATS
UP THEY HAD 70%.
IN THE NEXT ROUND.
DEMOCRATS NEEDED TO HAVE
SOME SERIOUS GAINS IN SENATE
LAST WEEK TO STAVE OFF A
DISASTER IN 2024.
THEY FAILED.
I'M NOT BEING A POLLY ANNA,
I AM JUST LAYING IT OUT.
THERE IS A LOT THERE OF
OPPOSITE VIEW POINT.
WHAT ABOUT THE RED WAVE OR A
G.O.P. PICK UP, MAYBE 6
SENATE SEATS, HEARD THAT
TOO.
THAT NEFF GOING TO HAPPEN.
-- NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN,
ONE SEAT OR TWO.
AT THE OUTSKIRTS MAYBE 3.
POSSIBLE.
WE WOULD HAVE TO HOLD ALL 20
REPUBLICAN SENATE SEATS AND
FLIP A FEW OF THE 14
DEMOCRAT SEAT, THEY HAVE A
LOT OF RESOURCES TO DEFEND
THEIR SEATS, A LOT MORE OF
THE MAP TO TAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD GO ON
OFFENSE.
WHAT HAPPENED?
ARIZONA A DEMOCRAT
INCUMBENT.
NEVADA, A DEMOCRAT
NEW HAMPSHIRE A DEMOCRAT
INCUMBENT, AND GEORGIA A
DEMOCRAT
INCUMBENT.
FOCUS ON ARIZONA AND NEW
HAMPSHIRE, CANDIDATES
RUNNING AGAINST THE DEMOCRAT
INCUMBENT AND SENATE
LEADERSHIP FUND MADE A
FATEFUL DECISION.
IT DECIDE THAT IT WOULD
PROVIDE NOT ONE PEN OF
SUPPORT TO BLAKE MASTERS IN
ARIZONA.
IT DECIDED TO PULL ABOUT 6
MILLION DOLLARS OF SUPPORT
IN LAST WEEK TO GENERAL
BOLDUC IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
WHO?
CHARGE OF THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP FUND?
MITCH MCCONNELL, THIS FUND
RAISED WELL OVER 100 MILLION
DOLLARS, HE CONTROLS IT.
SO NOT ONE PENNY TO ARIZONA.
HE PULLED 6 MILLION OUT OF
NEW HAMPSHIRE IN FINAL WEEK.
IT WAS MOST NEEDED THEN,
WHAT ELSE?
THEY POURED MILLION TO
COLORADO, COLORADO RACE.
TO SUPPORT A RINO WHO GOT
CRUSHED THAT ELECTION WAS
CALLED SOON AFTER POLLS
CLOSED.
THERE WAS AN EFFORT BY
DCG.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT
TO SAY THAT KIND OF
CANDIDATE IS THE KIND OF
CANDIDATE WE WANT, HE GO THE
BLOWN OUT, AND MILLIONS OF
WASTED.
AND THE FUND SPENT NEARLY 9
MILLION THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
USEDDED IN ARIZONA AND NEW
HAMPSHIRE, AND OTHER STATES
WHERE THEY WERE NEEDING
MONEY.
9 MILLION SPEARINGS
CANDIDATE IN LAS LAX
McCONNELL WANTED LISA
MURKOWSKI TO WIN.
ALMOST 9 MILLION DOLLARS
WASTED.
ALASKA WAS GOING TO SETTLE
REPUBLICAN NO MATTER WHAT,
THEY INTERFERED IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
AND BLEW 9 MILLION THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN USED IN
ARIZONA, NEW HAMPSHIRE,
NEVADA, GEORGIA.
AND OTHER PLACES, I NOTICE A
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS, ON
TELEVISION, COMING TO
DEFENSE OF ALL THIS.
THAT TELLS ME THEY HAVE A
STOCKHOLM SYNDROME, THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
TAKING PLACE IN THE NATION.
THEY MADE VERY POOR
DECISIONS TO THIS SENATE
LEADERSHIP FUND UNDER MITCH
MCCONNELL.
THEY DID SAME THING IN 2010
IN TEA PARTY.
ATTACKED THE TEA PARTY.
IT WAS SO-CALLED EXPERTS AND
CONSULTANTS AND G.O.P.
OPERATIVES AND POLITICIANS
THAT WASHINGTON WHO DID THIS
.
AFTER THE RESULTS,
REPUBLICAN DC ESTABLISHMENT
WENT ON THE ATTACK, THEY
MAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
NOTHING, CANDIDATES WHO YOU
VOTED FOR IN REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY, WHATEVER STATE, WHO
YOU VOTED FOR.
THE PRIMARY VOTER.
YOU CHOSE FLAWED CANDIDATES.
IT IS YOUR FAULT.
YOUR FAULT.
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
IT IS YOUR FAULT IN
PENNSYLVANIA, IT IS YOUR
FAULT -- THAT IS THEIR
RESPONSE OF THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT.
SOME OF THESE CANDIDATES WHO
LOST COST US THE ELECTION,
THEY SAY BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP SUPPORTED THEM.
AND IF THE VOTERS AND TRUMP
HAD LEFT IT UP TO THE
EXPERTS IN WASHINGTON, THE
G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT THEIR
CONSULTANTS, MANY OF WHOM
YOU KNOW THEY'RE TO CHOOSE
CANDIDATES RATHER THAN
PEOPLE, WE WOULD HAVE WON
MORE SEATS.
WHO SAYS?
BASED ON WHAT?
BASED ON NOTHING.
THEY SAID THE SAME THING IN
2010 DURING THE TEA PARTY
REVOLUTION, THEY TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR NOTHING,
THEY HAD THE MONEY, THEY
DECIDED WHERE IT WENT.
THERE WAS NEVER GOING TO BE
THIS WAVE, PERIOD.
MATH MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT IF SENATE LEADERSHIP
FUND SPENT ITS MONEY MORE
PRUDENTLY WE MIGHT HAVE
PICKED UP A COUPLE MORE
SEATS.
WHAT THE HOUSE?
A DIFFERENT STORY, SEVERAL
MORE MILLION REPUBLICANS
THAT VOTED THAN DEMOCRAT BUS
WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
FRACTION OF HOW "THE
INDEPENDENTS" -- GRASK ON
GRASP ON HOW
INDEPENDENTS VOTED, 25 OR SO
HOUSE RACE THAT WERE DECIDE
BY LESS THAN 5% OF THE VOTE.
LESS THAN 5% OF THE VOTE.
SEVERAL CLOSER.
UP -- THERE ALMOST WAS A
SO-CALLED RED WAVE IN THE
HOUSE, BUT THEY FELL SHORT.
THEY FELL SHORT.
ALL THIS SEATS INVOLVED DEM
DEMOCRAT INCUMBENT.
IT IS LIKELY THE REPUBLICANS
WILL TAKE THE HOUSE BY A
SMALLER NUMBER.
THEY APPOINT
SPEAKER, CONTROL THE
COMMITTEE, LEAD UP TO
ELECTION, POLLSTERS, AND
REPUBLICAN OPERATIVES IN
DC .
WERE TALKING ABOUT A RED
WAVE AS IF IT OCCURRED.
WHAT ARE THEY BASED IT ON,
IT WAS FLAWED.
I SAID OVER AND OVER.
IGNORE THEM.
THEY ARE ALWAYS FLAWED AND
INACCURATE.
ALL RIGHT.
THE DEMOCRAT AND MEDIA ARE
CELEBRATES, WHAT?
>> RED WAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
IT WASN'T GOING TO HAPPEN.
NOT IN THE SENATE FOR SURE.
BUT THEY ARE DILUTING
THEMSELVES, DEMOCRATS MADE
NO PROGRESS IN SENATE, THEY
NEEDED.
AT BEST ONE SEAT.
WHEN MATH WAS 100% WITH
THEM, 100%.
IN 2024, THEY ARE
IN -- HORRENDOUS
SITUATION 2/3 OF SENATE
SEATS COMING UP ARE DEMOCRAT
SEATS, THEY CELEBRATE THEY
LOST HOUSE BY A RELATIVE FEW
VOTES, BUT THEY LOST THE
HOUSE, G.O.P. CAN NOW BLOCK
THE RADICAL KOOK PROGRAMS
THATTED BY SENSE PUSHING.
-- THAT BIDEN IS PUSHING
AND THEY DAMN WELL BETTER,
BUT IF REPUBLICAN ALLOW SAME
DC ESTABLISHMENT.
IF THEY ALLOW THEM TO
CONTROL THE AGENDA AND
MONEY, THE FUTURE IS BLEAK.
RONALD REAGAN WON 2 MASSIVE
LANDSLIDES, HE WAS NOT PART
OF THE ESTABLISHMENT.
DONALD TRUMP WAS NOT PART OF
THE ESTABLISHMENT.
HE WAS A CONSERVATIVES,
CONSERVATIVES DELIVERED
HOUSE IN 2020, AND
CONSERVATIVES OUT THERE ARE
THOSE WHO HELD DEMOCRATS
THIS ELECTION CYCLE.
DON'T FORGET IT.
THE MESSAGE IS LISTEN TO THE
WASHINGTON EXPERTS, THE
WASHINGTON ESTABLISHMENT,
THE LONG IN TOOTH THE
PART AND GET SMEARED.
DON'T LISTEN TO THEM.
AND HATED TRUMP.
AND WHO ARE NOW ATTACKING
THE BASE AGAIN.
PRIMARY VOTERS.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T DO THIS
TO THEIR BASE OR SUPPORTERS.
SO TWO SCENARIOS, FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT RED WAVE COULD BE HERE
BUT IN 2024.
THAT FLORIDA WAS TIP OF THE
SPEAR, A BLOWOUT UNDER THE
GREAT GOVERNOR OF --
AMERICA'S GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS.
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
BE SPREAD IF PEOPLE GOVERN
LIKE CONSERVATIVES.
THE SENATE WILL BE MATH
POSITIONED FOR GOVERNMENTS
TO GET BIG GAINS.
WE HAVE TWO MORE YEARS OF
BIDEN DISASTERS, NOT GETTING
BETTER, IT WILL GET WORSE.
OR ON THE DARK SIDE, IT IS
CONCEIVABLE, CULTURE ROCK IS
SO UBIQUITOUS THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH AMERICAN-LOVING
PATRIOTS TO WIN ELECTIONS,
THAT IS